hi uh my name is itamar uh you can find
uh lots of Articles I've written about
uh python performance and other issues
at pythons speed.com um I work as a
consultant I Bren some software tools uh
and this is a talk about priorities uh
what should you do first what should you
do
second and so before we start talking
about software performance the sort of
thing you should be thinking about even
before that is whether or not the
software you're writing
uh should exist at all if your software
you're working on hurts people if the
software you're working on damages the
environment then if you make your
software faster then you're just causing
damage faster uh and
so before you start thinking about
should this software be faster you
should be thinking about should this
software exist at all and if it
shouldn't then you can go find a
different job and then in that new job
you can think about software
performance so I'm going to asse that
you're working on something very useful
and great and I hope you all
are and now I just like to set the scene
uh so software performance software
speed is a very situational kind of
thing uh if you think about a web
application you want it to be very
responsive uh it's about how quickly you
get back a response how quickly you
interact uh and often the battl necks
involve how the user interface works how
interactions with the browser work on
the back end the bottlenecks are
interactions the database that's a web
application is very different than what
I'll be talking about today which is
data
processing and so what I'm talking about
here is within a very specific domain
and some of the really deep underlying
principles you can always translate but
you always have to think about what your
particular goal is in a particular
situation so what I'm talking about
today is data processing a lot closer to
to the topic of this conference uh
things like scientific Computing uh
things like data science when you're
processing the data um and more broadly
the the class of tasks where you read in
some data you do some sort of processing
and write at a result and even more
specifically I'm talking about software
where the CPU is the
bck uh if
you again talking to a database and all
your interactions are SQL queries the
way you'll make your software faster is
by optimizing the SQL queries adding an
index it's not what we're talking about
today today we're talking about code
where the computation you're running uh
or maybe memory rights are but the
actual computation you're doing is the
bomic and that's sort of the constraint
of this discussion the scenario we're
talking
about the specific problem we're talking
about is slow software
uh and slow software is ubiquitous uh
and it comes with a whole group of
different problems that result from this
underlying issue uh so if your software
takes a long time to run then
development can be very difficult you
want to try a new version of your
algorithm but it takes an hour to see
whether or not it's better so now you
can do at most five or six experiments a
day and that can really slow down how
fast you improve your code if you get
down from 1 hour to 5 minutes then now
you can do things much much
faster uh if you have users using your
code uh once it's in production and they
are waiting for responses if the
software takes too long to get a
response they will be unhappy uh the
faster it is probably the happier
they'll be in most situations not always
sometimes it doesn't matter but in
general people are happier when they get
results back
faster uh if you're running your
software at scale uh you're going to end
up uh paying higher bills for running
your software um if you're scaling up
you have thousands of users you're
running lots of computers if you can uh
if you have to support more people then
now you have to spend more money uh on
computers or cloud computing and finally
since everything here is work running on
electricity if you're using source of
electricity that is non
sustainable uh the more computation do
you do the more electricity you use the
more CO2 emissions we have uh and data
centers in general are uh every
increasing percentage of global CO2
emissions so uh it's nice to use less
resources so that's our problem our
software is slow uh so how are we going
to solve this so one theoretical
solution to say well we have some
algorithm it runs on one CPU we can just
buy a faster CPU
uh and here I'm talking just about the
speed of a single core so the speed of a
single thread that's running on your
computer uh and there's a or company
called PassMark and they run have people
run benchmarks and lots of different CPU
models I say look at the numbers for CPU
in my computer it's probably a year
couple years old at this point uh and on
their Benchmark it's 450 higher is
better in this measure so the higher the
number the faster you are and in their
database the fastest single core CPU
that is a single thread speed is that
recently released Apple M3 Pro it's
4,800 compared to 450 from y CPU so it
is basically not possible to buy a CPU
that is much faster than this on single
course speed like you just can't doesn't
matter how much money you have if you
have a really ridiculous like if I'm
sure if you had like $10 million you
could get something but you would be
like 10% faster 20% faster 30% faster
it's very hard limit so getting a faster
single core CPU is just fundamentally
not workable it's not a viable
solution uh this is not going to
work so next thing we can consider is
well let's use parallelism right my
computer has something like uh depending
how you think of it between 10 and 12
CPUs some of them are not quite as fast
as the others uh and so we can see again
the benchmarks uh and you can see that
previously it was 4,000 for single core
once I'm using all the cores in my
computer uh if I have a parallel program
I get up to 30 around 35,000 so it's a
lot
faster uh and in the database of this
Benchmark company PassMark there's a one
CPU that has like it's like five times
as fast of that and my guess is that
there are actually CPUs that are faster
than that that they just don't include
because uh they're not really available
to Consumers but like if you're like
running a cluster you can get probably
even faster CPUs that have lots and lots
of cores as long as you can run in
parallel you can just go faster so here
like you spend more money you get five
times as fast that's great on my
computer I can just scale up to all the
CPUs I'm going faster that's
great uh so that means is
multi-threading multiprocessing running
your code in parallel is a great way to
speed up your
code and then a third way to speed up
your code is optimizing your software
that is somehow changing your code so
that it runs faster on a single
core uh then if it runs faster a single
core if you run it in parallel that will
also be correspondingly
faster but there are some caveats here
um if you're using numpy or scipi or
pandas or any of these libraries you're
likely to be using in Python
uh your code that you're running is is
written in C or C++ or rest uh for Dr
and they're all quite fast much faster
than
python that's why you're using NPI or
CPI or pandis and that being the case
that suggests that there isn't much more
you can do to make software faster
you're sort of you've gone from slow
python to fast C now your code is fast
and is there anything more you can do
unclear and so at this point lots of
people conclude that the way to go move
forward is parallelism we know we can't
get faster single core CPUs like it's
just not commercially available there's
hard limits on current engineering
technology you can get CPUs that have
lots and lots and lots of
cores just throw money at the problem
you'll get a machine with lots more
CPUs and those are both facts uh and
they strongly influence how you write
software and then there's an
assumption that optimizing software is
not
possible and as we'll see I think that
is often not the case and so the
conclusion is that if your software is
slow you should immediately switch to
multi-threading multiprocessing you need
to switch to parallel programming in
order to go
faster and so the rest of this talk is a
counterargument against this way of
thinking uh we'll start by talking about
why focusing only on parallelism can be
a problem
uh I'll argue that your software
probably can be optimized even on a
single core you could probably make it
run much faster what that suggest is you
should first optimize yourself or first
try to make it run quickly on a single
core then once you spent the effort on
that you should focus on paralyzing
it and so we'll start about talking
about some limits of parallelism why
it's not as good a solution as you might
think so first
uh and this is sort of a fundamental
limit some algorithms cannot be
parallelized and sometimes this is in
full sometimes there's just no way to
make the algorithm parallel just because
of the way it processes data every piece
of computation depends on other pieces
in your data set and so you can't split
your data set into two chunks and
process them in
parallel uh sometimes you can only
parallelize part of the algorithm um
there's amell's law which is a way to
calculate uh the resulting performance
of your code if you can only paraliz
part of
it um this is all very domain specific
it's all very algorithm specific it's
very difficult to say in abstract
whether or not your code is
parallelizable but sometimes it just
isn't uh and when it isn't there are
workarounds in particular even if the
algorithm can't run in parallel if you
have to process 100 files and those
files can be processed independently
then you can run a single-threaded
algorithm on multiple files in parallel
so file one is on One Core file two is
another core so even if the algorithm
isn't parallel you might still be able
to get
parallelism so it's not as big
constraint as it can be this assumes
though that you have multiple inputs if
you just have one giant input that you
can't split up then you're
stuck another limit is that parallelism
doesn't reduce costs and here I'm
talking about uh like monetary cost
Financial cost the cost of the hardware
that you're using to run
it if you were to make software more
efficient if you're to optimize it make
it run faster that has two benefits you
get results faster so instead of taking
an hour maybe it takes 10 minutes and
also you're using less computer
time uh which as we'll see in a second
can save you somebody and parallelism
can only give you the first benefit if
you're using multiple
CPUs uh that is giving you results
faster and that's great but it's not
reducing how much computation you're
using which means the C the the monetary
cost of running the computation doesn't
go
down and we can think of this in two
scenarios so one is you have your own
computer under your desk or a laptop
that you're running your computation
on uh so you can look here are the
performance numbers The Benchmark they
showed uh again for the i7 12 12,700 K
is a CPU in my computer uh it costs
about $400 to buy the CPU plus you have
to buy the rest of the computer just
focusing on the CPU if I run in a single
thread uh I'm running at speed of 4,000
based on this Benchmark Suite uh if I
use all the cores and I run in multiple
threads it's 35,000 so great I'm running
nine times faster and either way I spend
$400 right so parallelism uh in this
case is great it is actually saving me
money because I can then go and run some
more if I want to go
faster I need to buy a more powerful CPU
and this is when things start getting uh
a little uh more expensive because
you'll notice that this other CPU this
is the fastest multi-core CPU in this
particular
database uh you can buy it cost $10,000
just for the CPU all the RAM and whatnot
will cost you a lot more and you'll get
a five times speed up but the jump in
price from $400 to $10,000 is not five
times as much it's 25 times as much so
you're running five times as fast but
you're paying 25 times as much uh so
it's a big jump in costs in order to go
faster uh and
so at some point the the like you start
spending a lot more money to get more
parallelism on a single CPU and you can
build a cluster out of Cheaper computers
but now you're dealing with a
distributed system and your programming
job just got a lot
harder and the another scenario here is
cloud computing you're renting time on
the cloud from AWS or Azure or Google
cloud or any one of their competitors
and here your costs the first
approximation scale linearly with a
number of
cores uh
so uh you don't really have the issue of
these sort of jump giant jumps in price
so if you want to run five times faster
you're going to spend five times as much
money right you get five times get
instead of two cores you go to 10 cores
and now you're
uh the virtual machine you're renting in
the cloud is going to cost you five
times as
much if you want to
run five times faster but just optimize
your software if you can figure out some
way to make your software five times
faster by some of the techniques we'll
discuss next you're running five times
faster at no extra runtime cost and if
you're only running your software once
you don't want to do this right if
you're going to run a like process a
data one time just rent a cloud in the
the rent a virtual machine in the cloud
with 40 CPUs it runs really fast you
spend $20 you shut it down you're
done uh problem solved but if you're
scaling up if you're running your batch
jobs at a larger scale or
continuously then parallelism is not
saving you any money it's just moving
the costs around whereas making your
faster software your software faster can
actually reduce your costs by reducing
how much CPU time you need to
use so parallelism is not perfect it's
very useful but it has some limits and
so next we'll see just at a very quick
overview of the ways in which you could
it is actually possible to make your
software
faster and software performance comes
from uh multiple levels of
uh the way you write your software at
the highest level is architecture and
then there's algorithms uh there's just
optimizing your code so it doesn't
doesn't do unnecessary work you can tune
it for modern
CPUs uh and each of these levels you
probably want to address in order of
priority like architecture has the
biggest impact than
algorithms so
again uh a large part of how you get
performance is how your prioritizer work
uh and if you have a good architecture
you can get speed ups that would be
impossible with a bad
architecture and you know only have you
know 25 minutes uh so can't go into
depth on any of these but I can at least
give some
examples so if you're processing data
frames you have a number of
libraries the most popular one is pandas
but polers is a new Contender that uh
has has been getting a lot of users
recently if you're not familiar uh if
you never Ed these uh the basic data
model there helping with is columnar
data that has a type and a name so
basically a spreadsheet kind of data um
so you have different columns or
different types and you're processing
them processing
them and if you're using pandas to
process your data every time you tell it
to do something it does it immediately
so you say I want to sum this column it
will some the column and give you the
result I want to load this file it will
immediately load the data into memory I
want to filter this the rows of this
criteria it'll immediately filter the
data and polers which is uh also has a
mode that works like this eager mode but
it also has a lazy mode and in polar's
lazy mode it doesn't actually do the
work immediately instead you have to
give it all the things you want to do
it's a do and then you say okay these
this is all the steps I want you to do
now actually do the work so you say I
want you to load this file and then
filter it and then summarize it and then
group it by this column okay that's
everything you're GNA and then output it
here now that's everything you're going
to be doing now go into
it and what that means is polers knows
your plan end to endend it knows your
goal it's not doing step by step what
you what you're telling it to do it's
trying to achieve the equivalent of what
you told it to do and so it can say okay
this is what you want me to do I can
optimize your code I can optimize your
plan and come up with something that
gives equivalent results but it's faster
and this is for example how a SQL
database works when you do a complicated
SQL query the database will figure out
via a set of juristic uh what things to
do first so that it gets you the results
as quickly as
possible
and just to give it a sense of what kind
of optimizations you do if you are
filtering rows that means if any r that
you filter out there's no point in doing
any processing on because you just fil
you're throwing it away and so polar's
query planner will try to move all the
filtering as early as possible in its
execution plan so that it drops all the
data as soon as possible that any steps
later on that are more expensive only
happen in data you actually care about
and it does this for you automatically
if you're using the lazy
mode and so there's a fundamental
architectural difference between pandas
and polar's lazy mode panda
architecturally cannot do this the whole
way it's designed is to do whatever you
tell it
immediately and so there are performance
improvements that polers can do that are
impossible in pandas and this isn't like
polers also does parallelism which is
very nice but this isn't about that this
is even in on a single CPU by just being
smarter about how it's architected it's
able to give you performance benefits
are impossible with a different
architecture and so next let's look look
at an example of algorithmic speed up um
so obviously you want your algorithms to
scale and uh so this is part of your
design criteria but it's also easy to
accidentally write code that is uh
non-scalable um in particular
accidentally quadratic algorithms where
the runtime is the square of the length
of the input N
squared are very common um there's
actually a BG a Blog called accidentally
quadratic you can read it has many
examples uh and this particular example
is taken from
there uh
so in the Mercurial uh Version Control
System
um someone noticed that some code was
slow and then they figured out they were
basically trying to find the overlap of
two lists which is takes square of the
length of the lists uh and for by
switching to one of the lists to a set
uh they got the runtime down from 18
seconds to 1.3 seconds this particular
task as you'll notice it's only five
extra characters and so someone typed
five extra characters and now their code
is running 15 16 times
faster right and it's not like this
happens every day but it is a real issue
acally quadratic code is actually quite
common uh and so if your algorithm is N
squared if it's not scalable it doesn't
matter how many CPUs you throw at it it
doesn't matter that you're using C
instead of python like if you have 10
times as much data input it will take a
100 times longer to run it's just not
going to scale at all uh so using the
right algorithms can give you really
massive
speedups so you have a good architecture
you have a good
algorithm in terms of
scalability there's still a lot more you
can do so uh
I this is a very rescaling intensity is
a very common thing in image processing
it's just changing the
contrast uh like every time you take a
photo on your phone and like drag around
the
contrast U slider you're doing the same
thing your phone's trying to do it
automatically for you when you take a
picture um so pyit image has a ver has
an
implementation uh and if you optimize it
a little bit um you can make it around
four times faster um and if you write an
optimized version of the lookup table uh
which limits you to 8bit images but um
it's that much more faster uh and these
are all o and they're all linear runtime
but the constant multiplier the how much
it takes to write in each step is much
much lower and so you get a really
significant speed
up uh this is a lookup table version
just uh so you can see it so it's really
not that much code you just uh and it
could probably be even faster this is
mostly written for educational purposes
uh so not very much code and you get a
really huge speed up by just figuring
out that you were just calculating the
same thing over and over and over again
and if you just cach it in a lookup
table and only calculate it once
suddenly your calculation is much much
faster as an as side the I just
mentioned that the version in psyched
image uh open source library is slow uh
I do not mean this as a criticism of the
maintainers uh the people who work on
these libraries are doing it in their
spare time they have very limited
resources uh if you're in Academia
you're not getting credit for work on
open source libraries much of the time
um and so just don't have time to work
on performance and also they're trying
to support general purpose use cases and
so that can work against performance
your code is specialized and so you can
also you might be able to optimize it
for your specific data and its specific
properties and once you've gotten rid of
wasted work you can also try optimizing
your code for modern
CPUs uh and this is an example from a a
article on my
website uh where uh we want to threshold
some data we want to
um reduce the noise uh anything below
certain noise level in the image we want
to set to zero because it's just noise
so you can see there's two ver here one
with
numpy and one that's written with Numba
with a code that's written specifically
with understanding of how modern CPUs
work they use a lot of tricks to go
really fast but you have to understand
them to actually get that
speed and you can see you got really big
speed up and on your computer it might
be a little different and might be quite
as good but you can get really
significant speedups just by tuning your
code to based on how CPUs work to take
advantage of things like instruct level
processing and simd and other CPU
features and this is the thing you do
all the way at the end but even here you
can still get significant speed ups and
all the speedups you get from
architecture down to this level of
tuning are cumulative uh and so you can
get the multip like a multiple like
they're multiplicative so you can go
much much faster than your original code
if you work on all these
levels
so probably don't want to parallelize
your code as a first thing sometimes
it's not possible at all only partially
possible it can sort of obscure the fact
that you're using inefficient
code uh which might be in some cases
very easy to fix like you might be able
to spend an hour and have your code be
four times faster 10 times faster or not
it depends but sometimes you can you
should check and if you're trying to
lower costs like if you want to spend
less money on computation parallelism
does not
help on the other hand if you optimize
your code first it will reduce your
Computing
costs uh it is possible your code is
quite often less efficient than it could
be uh the dependencies you rely on the
libraries you're using are often less
efficient than they could be you can
submit patches open source projects to
speed them up you can write your own
version of the algorithm that's tuned to
your particular
requirements and if you think about your
think about your architecture from a
perspective of optimizing it it may also
give you more opportunity for
parallelism so po because it has a in
lazy mode because it has an query
planner it can also use that to add
parallelism in a way that' be more much
more difficult in
pandas but you still want to paralyze
your software uh if you're using your
local computer your local computer has a
lot of cores even cheap laptops these
days have four CPUs cores so your
software will run faster without
spending any more money still worth it
for cloud computing uh if optimization
isn't enough like at least you'll get
results faster or you can process more
data without uh increasing your response
time so parallelism is very definitely
worth it but you should approach it
second after optimizing your
software so that's my talk uh I have a
bunch of Articles at pythons speed.com
uh you can find the slides at pythons
speed.com pyat Global 23 uh I work as a
consultant so I can help maybe speed up
your software and I'm working on a book
focusing on the last two levels of
optimization I talked about getting rid
of unnecessary work and tuning for
modern CPUs and please email me with any
questions you may
have that's wonderful thank you for the
talk um folks we got a few minutes left
I believe where's my clock there we go
yeah if there's any questions feel free
to put them in the chat
um and uh we'll see what we can
do uh there's a question here uh is
there any scope for interoperability of
python with C C++ or even Russ is a
strategy for optimizing python
algorithm yeah so in the question was
yeah can you speed up uh with lowl code
and yeah like in general for this kind
of processing um
uh large like if you're processing lots
of data you pretty much want to be using
a faster lowle language like rust or C
or scon or
NBA um if you look back at my examples
they're using Numba which is a just in
time kind of sort of compiler basically
it's giving you it's equiv to writing
stuff in and C or rest it's compiling to
machine code and that's part of the
speed up but only part of
it
awesome um and I see another question I
might have missed did you already answer
uh does your cost analysis and the limit
number one only apply to on Prem CPU
cost uh so if you I there's two examples
there of uh both on-prem and cloud and
in
Cloud it scales linearly uh so if you
want like four times as many cores
typically you'll pay four times as much
so you can pay four times as much and
run in a quarter of the time and it just
bounces out and so parallelism does not
reduce your costs gets you faster
results if you have perfect parallelism
but it does not reduce your costs as
soon as you don't scale perfectly with
uh most more CPUs you actually end up
paying more um but yeah you you can't
save money by using more cors
typically interesting um another
question and I think we got time for two
last ones here so uh do you have any
recommendations for profiling
tools uh
so uh I work on I've created a profile
of my own uh SCI agraph
sky.com um it's also linked my website
probably uh but it's commercial uh and
does memory and performance profiling uh
for open source uh memor is a great
memory profiler pypy or Austin are great
um profilers for python programs
and they profile down to native code and
then once you're down to like optimizing
IND native code you want to use things
like Linux perf or other tools platform
specific tools so it sort of depends on
what level you're profiling at